I and you are very useful shorthand even
though at some level they're Illusions
um they're very useful shorthand for the
the system of my brain really and you
know and my body the the whole system
that I is useful for that but the
illusion is when we feel like there's
something outside of that system that
can intervene that is free that's
somehow free from the physical world
um I can have the thought
um yeah I really not crazy about having
intellectual back and forth on Twitter
and then
feel like I decide to not follow that
thought right and the feeling that's
that that's the feeling
um where the illusion comes in because
it really feels as if sure my brain had
that original thought and then I came in
and made a different decision but of
course the truth is it was just further
brain processing that got me to decide
not to go down that path how much is
that feeling of conscious will is
culturally constructed shorthand so like
uh I and you is a is a you could say a
culturally constructed shorthand
how much of that
affects how we think so our parents say
I and you I and you and then we start to
believe in I in you and is that or are
we is that fundamental to the human
brain machine yeah that we I think I
think it goes very deep I think it's
fundamental and I think it probably some
form of feeling like a self goes
as deep as cats and dogs and it's
possible I mean if consciousness
does go down to the level of cells or
however far down you want to take it
worms or I think any any system that's
navigating
um itself that kind of has boundaries
and is navigating itself in the world
um my guess is that it's it's an
intrinsic part of that's why I imagined
that the P tendril would have this
feeling
um and so you know
we use the word I I think you're right
first of all that the way we talk about
things affects our intuitions about them
and how we feel about them and so there
are other cultures who are more open
to breaking through these Illusions than
others for sure just because of their
um their belief sets the way they talk I
mean I'm sure I don't I don't I'm not a
linguist and I don't even speak a second
language so I can't I can't speak to it
but I you know if if there were a
language that
um
that framed
who we are differently in everyday
language I mean in our everyday
communication I would think that would
have an effect yeah language does affect
things I mean just knowing Uh Russian in
the history of the Soviet Union in the
20th century obviously it lived under
communism for a long time so your
conception of individualism is different
and that reflects itself from the
language yeah um you could probably have
this similar kind of thing
within the language
in terms of how we talk about I and we
and so on yeah and I yeah I'm sure
there's like um certain countries or
maybe even villages with certain
dialects that uh
like let go of the individualism that's
inherent yeah I mean there there must be
a range but I do think that it's pretty
deep and I think
um
there's also a difference between the
autobiographical me and then this more
fundamental me that that we're talking
about where that I'm pointing to is the
illusion so in my book I talk about if
someone
um wakes up with amnesia if they have a
brain injury and suddenly have amnesia
and can't remember anything about their
lives can't remember their name don't
recognize people they're related to
um
they would have lost their
autobiographical self but they would
still feel like an eye they would still
have that basic sense of I'm a person I
mean they'd be speaking that way I don't
remember my name I don't know where I
live
um you still it goes very deep this
feeling that I am a single entity
um that is somehow
not completely Reliant upon the cause
and effect of the physical world can I
ask you a pothead question yeah
um would you
would you
rather lose all your memories or not be
able to make new ones
you get to now I'm asking you as a human
yeah in terms of happiness and
preference
I can't answer that you like both you
like both features of the organism that
you embody
well one is intellectual and one is
psychological really I mean I would have
to choose the memories only because I
mean memories of the past yeah
um only because I have children and a
family and it would just be it wouldn't
just be affecting me it would be
affecting them it would just be too
horrible
no but you would make new ones right
if I lost my memory of the 13 pounds you
think would you you think you would lose
this is a dark question oh wait wasn't
that the question maybe I missed no no
no no you understood it perfectly but
yeah
you you know sorry for the dark question
but the people you love in your life if
you lost all your memory of everything
do you think you would still love them
like you show up you don't know I don't
know to roll the die I mean it would not
in the way that I do right just some
deep aspect of Love is the history you
have together oh absolutely well and
this gets to an interesting point
actually which I think a lot about which
is memory
um and we won't go into this yet but
I'll just plant a flag here memory is
yeah memories um obviously related to
time and time is something that I'm
fascinated with and and for this project
I'm working on now I've mostly been
speaking to physicists who are
interested in Consciousness
um and it's partly because of this link
between memory and time and you know all
of these new fascinating
um theories and thoughts around the
different interpretations of quantum
mechanics and
looking at you know the thing that I've
always been looking for is is really the
fundamental nature of reality and why
my questions about Consciousness lead me
to wonder if Consciousness is a more
fundamental aspect of the universe than
than we previously thought and certainly
I previously thought
um and so memory but memory is is tied
to so many things I mean even
basic functions in nature actually so so
the the pitendril as I mentioned memory
comes into play there and that's so
fascinating
um and there is no sense of self without
memory even if you're starting from
scratch as you said with amnesia
um if you truly couldn't lay down any
new memories I think you would then that
sense of self would begin to
disintegrate because the sense of self
is one of a concrete entity Through Time
and if each moment if you really were
stuck in the present moment
eternally you'd be basically be
meditating
and in meditation is a very common
experience is losing that sense of self
that sense of free will that those
Illusions
um more easily drop away in meditation
and I would say for most people who
meditate long enough they do drop away
and there's actually an explanation of
the level of the brain as well the
default mode network is circuitry in the
brain that neuroscientists don't
completely understand but no is is
largely largely responsible for this
feeling of being a self
um and when that circuit gets quieted
down which it does in meditation and
also does
um with the use of psychedelic drugs
um and there are other ways to quiet
down the default mode Network
um people have this experience of losing
this this illusion of being a self they
no longer feel that they're self in the
way that they usually do so there's uh
the autobiographical self is connected
to the the sense of self oh absolutely
through the memory and then you're
thinking that the solution to that lies
in physics not just Neuroscience like
ultimately Consciousness and the
experience the conscious will
is uh a question of physics
I may have said something misleading
because I was connecting too many dots
um misleading
um let us mislead each other I just got
I got excited when memory came up
because I love talking about time